hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem weiteren kontakt hier auf meinem
kanal am sonntag kommt ja im areal
live-videos neuerdings und zwar habe ich
letzte woche gesagt dass ich heute
entweder 20 dinge die ich mag oder eure
kommentare beantworten werde allerdings
werde ich keins von beiden machen
entschuldigung und zwar habe ich bei not
tut also dieser komische typ damit dem
ich gta online mache habe ich ein video
gesehen wo er youtube unterhalte
nachsynchronisiert hat und ich habe mir
gedacht war das ist so geil ich werde es
einfach auch mal machen und wir haben
das alles genehmigt dass es nicht seine
idee war dass er schon überall anders
mal gemacht wurde
also braucht ihr euch das gar nicht
beschweren ich hab's normal gemacht und
das wollte jetzt einfach mal machen und
ich hab mir da jetzt einfach mal das
video genommen was ich da im letzten
kontakt draußen gemacht habe wo ich
draußen stand und hab da einfach mal
versucht so rüber zu quatschen wie als
ich draußen stand natürlich ist die
tonqualität eine komplett andere wie
draußen mit myphone als jetzt hier mit
mode mikrofon aber ich hoffe euch
gefällt es trotzdem und erstmal viel
spaß dabei
dort hatte er das ist jetzt einfach mal
zurück dass das in ende so what
nichtrauchen zusammenfassung kommen so
ganz nach ruhe so das übermaß unter der
woche etwas auf werde was sich dann halt
so macht er jagd ende packen
und jetzt ammann bet-at-home frei
bekommen wo braucht vielleicht auch
etwas weg zum selbst zog roger cicero 62
zu viel zeigt ich stehe aber optik und 8
also packen werden weggedrückt
opferfestes schubkraft man auch abrufen
robert brochtrup wirken
das ist nicht mehr so toll aus europa
allerdings an es hat etwas versprochen
ist ärger bereiten august setzt er
völlig außer dass sich das wasser gut 1
prozent ich hoffe war steht unter dem
strich 4 4 wurde ich in hamburg oder
mord mal gebrochen
die opfer stehen wollten würden petra
ihr programm us- open- wies ihre meinung
was aber noch aus ja und das war halt
dich nicht gespielt von iris berben vor
allem dieses ende soll ja das war halt
nicht gespielt von witz werben so
richtig aus dem konzept gerissen einfach
youtube du bist einfach an manchen
stellen ist total scheiße aber diese
sache ist echt so schlecht dass es
einfach schon wieder so witzig ist das
ist so geil ja jedenfalls bezüglich der
woche zusammenfassung habe ich nur am
montag dienstag und mittwoch etwas
gefilmt das blende ich euch jetzt mal
ganz kurz ein und zwar am montag musste
ich lernen für eine klausur am dienstag
oder habe ich euch jetzt einen super
tipp mit auf den weg gegeben
durch meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen am montag zu den ersten
ich dachte mal herrn und seiner wachen
zusammenfassung zum ersten teil und zwar
im league cup mein bett ist ließ gerade
glaube ich halb zwei und wenn ich
schreibe morgen deutsch lk klausuren
also lka das ist sowas wie sie das abo
fach was man dann auch schriftlich hat
ich schreibe deutscher und zwar möchte
ich euch einen wichtigen tipp mit auf
die reise bis zu ihrem abschluss geben
bis zum beenden der schule und zwar wenn
ihr lernen fand nicht einen tag vorher
an so vida loca und allerdings wenn ihr
das schon macht dann macht wenigstens
richtig weil ich komm trotzdem ganz cool
durch die schule und zwar was ich hier
so habe ist so kleine nicht später aber
so kleine kärtchen womit ich dazulernen
da steht ihr zum beispiel hier inhalt
mittlere 30 autoren entwerfen sachliche
typen vorkommenden personen sind
ingenieure kaufmänner frauen die analyse
besteht aus aspekten der wellenform
worte von klangfarben etc also solche
kleinen kärtchen dann einfach machen und
dann lege ich mich immer irgendwie ab
weil sie nicht 11 uhr ins bett und
lernen noch bis 2 uhr jetzt gerade und
ließ mich einfach die ganze zeit durch
also name tagsüber
wichtigsten aspekte zur klausur
schreiben als auch zwei kleine kätzchen
machen dann einfach immer mal angucken
am besten schon drei vier tage vor der
klausur anfang das immer angucken also
dass lukas lerntipps und jetzt geht es
weiter im konter weil ich jetzt kennen
am dienstag war es besonders witzig und
zwar habe ich da einen kontakt
aufgenommen ein wochen rauschen ist als
ich mit gommel christus kraft
aufgenommen habe in der christus kraft
folge hatten dass eventuell schon
gesehen dass ich da am hintergründen mal
so mit mandy sowieso gespielt hat und
das so gemacht habe hatte ich dabei
bisschen gestört
aber ich habe jetzt einfach mal die
zähne aus der perspektive von meinem
handy aufgenommen und die seht ihr jetzt
hallo freunde ich bin gerade auf leben
mit gott kommen wir gerade nicht der
rede die gezahlt
das ist gerade richtig komisch ich war
gleich erwartet aus also man hat kaum
reden ich bin gerade am aufnehmen ihr
seht da wird die spur damit ich handle
und jetzt habe ich ein bisschen dumm
gezweifelt dass meine tolle tolle band
und ja ich bin halt mit gog.com beim
aufnehmen chris muss kraft und sonst
geht weiter im programm heute ist ja und
der mittwoch der weg zum creepy tag und
zwar war ich da gerade vom sport wieder
gekommen es war nacht es war dunkel und
ich bin nach hause gefahren ich will
erstmal der polizei angehalten weil ich
kein licht hatte und kopfhörer drin
hatte also muss ich erst mal 25 euro
bezahlen und dann will ich
weitergefahren obwohl ich eigentlich
nicht durfte weil ich mal nicht nicht
hingekriegt habe das wieder hin zu
machen also nicht der polizeiwagen aber
ich hatte wirklich um fünf kilometer weg
vom sport bis nach hause dass es da
musste ich einfach fallen sonst war 7
haben sonst wäre ich um 9 uhr zu hause
gewesen ich hätte schieben müssen
naja jedenfalls bin ich dann die
schleichwege gefahren und auch so durch
den wald und alles möglich und das war
schon mega creepy und da habe ich auf
zwei ausschnitte gefüllt einmal ruhig
grad auf eine straße zu fahren
der andere wo ich gerade in einem wald
bin wo vollmond war und wo mir dann auf
einmal so große augen entgegen gekommen
sind das war ein fahrradfahrer mit so
zwei roten lämpchen die mit infrarot
lampen ich hab ich gedacht
die krise zwar so dunkel hessen zwei
rote augen hey leute ich bin auf dem
fahrrad nummern licht wand über dem
verlassenen weko krankenwagen ich wurde
gerade von der polizei angehalten weil
die vorne habe ich zwar nicht schön 25
euro welcher kopfhörer drin hatte und
die falsche straßenseite richtig geil
schade naja hab ich dem schönen fahrzeug
stark irgendwas gutes getan
mit welchem recht wieder an griechenland
fließen aber herzlich gehalten da ist
die straße über die ich jetzt super muss
und ich hoffe dass ich den ball nochmal
kommen beispiel einfach so wertvollen
mäßig weiter geplant und jacobacci
kleiner kurzer nachtrag ganze schleichen
hier
der garten ok entgegen alter ich hatte
schon angst der hatte sonne sonne rot
sondern rot ist nicht auf dem kopf und
hat zwei davon dass aus dieser rote
augen so am ende des tunnels halte nicht
erika und die letzten drei tage war ich
einfach jeden tag betrunken ein spaß war
einfach keine ahnung ich hab's vergessen
ich hatte viel zu tun ich war ja auch
mittlerweile immer von a nach b dann bin
ich meinen düsseldorf für mich magna da
sehr sehr viel unterwegs in letzter zeit
tut mir leid dass ich da jetzt nichts
zusammen fassen konnte allerdings soll
das halt nur so ich will jetzt nicht
jeden tag zusammen fassen sondern nur
mal so ab und zu allerdings habe ich
kenne crash gespielt hatte dass das
heftigste erlebnis in meinem ganzen
leben und zwar habt ihr schon mal das
hier erreicht in kandy crash habt ihr
das schon mal erreicht dass ihr drei
verdammte kekse hatte drei verdammte
keks in einem kenny crash level das ist
unglaublich das ist für mich so eine
weltneuheit
ich hab's noch nie hingekriegt das level
trotzdem nicht geschafft wenn i kenn di
kreis spielt schreibt man bei welchem
level ihr seid also es gibt jetzt eine
neue eulen dimension oder so aber die
meine ich nicht wenn man diese mega pc
einfach ich meine die normale dimension
ich bin glaube ich bei level 86 ich bin
mit 86 euro das kann man gar nicht
allerdings erkennen aber ich bin mir 86
also das immer gut
ja und sonst soll es auch eigentlich
schon wieder gewesen sein der kontakt
soll ja auch nicht immer so lange werden
der sollte eigentlich unter fünf minuten
bleiben der letzte boot schon so zehn
minuten lang also ist immer ein bisschen
viel finde ich möchte ich lieber mich in
kürze halt ein bisschen knackiger dass
ihr so was aus meinem real live
mitbekommt allerdings was kann ich noch
sagen was ist noch so passiert
eigentlich relativ wenig ich kann nur
sagen es am 24 dezember wahrscheinlich
eine richtig coole weihnachts animation
wiederkommen wird in minecraft und dass
ich eventuell skifahren werde über
weihnachten und dann werde ich meine
gopro mitnehmen dann werde ich das
filmen wie ich dann da bin und im schnee
herum spiele und eventuell dann mal im
pool bilden hotel und so was alles also
wollt ihr dass ich das so filme meine
haare sind wir gerade eine ecke wollt
ihr dass ich euch damit nehme so ein
kleinen roadtrip macht und den am
kontakt hochladen oder sagt die erde und
was interessiert mich das denn was du in
deinem urlaub macht will ich jetzt noch
abschließend sagen das war's mit dem
kontakt wir sehen uns dann in einer
woche im nächsten kontakt wieder bzw den
uns dann wieder wenn ihr wieder ein
video von mir anklicken werden
ich hoffe euch haben die beiden euch hat
die erfolge heute gefallen und auch die
gta folge der besonders witzig war gta
sex am projekt mittlerweile das macht
mir so viel spaß es ist richtig geil
jede folge sind immer mindestens zwei wm
trophäen vom anfang bald werde ich
übrigens auch noch ein neues intro haben
für gta werde ich mir kaufen und es dann
eben wie dubai arbeiten und ich hab kein
gamer mikrofon geschlagen und ich werde
doch bald wieder als normale kamera
mikro zu legen und die ganze qualität
wird sich dann noch mal verändern weil
ich halt zu weihnachten wahrscheinlich
einen kompressor equalizer auch bekommen
werden wir die ganze qualität noch mal
anders sein und dann würde ich sagen
wenn euch der kontakt trotzdem gefallen
hat auch wenn es ein bisschen nur noch
15 wieder war dann könnt ihr mir einfach
eine bewertung da lassen egal ob positiv
oder negativ einfach ganz viel bewerten
ob euch das gefällt der kontakt oder
nicht gibt einfach irgendwas ab das ist
mir relativ egal ob positiv oder negativ
ist halt einfach eure meinung
interessiert mich da und schreibt mir
halt in die kommentare ob ihr nächsten
kontakt 20 dinge die ich mag haben
möchtet oder eure kommentare beantwortet
weil dann könnt ihr das jetzt einfach
ein straße entweder kommentare oder
dinge die du magst irgendwie sowas
reinschreiben aber ich das mit den
gucken wer wie viel geschrieben hat dann
auswerten und dann eventuell am es um
die kommentare geht dann bei facebook
posten vom nächsten kontakt was ihr
fragen habt und blablabla schon alles
macht mit dem convention ist mal wieder
macht gut